there's a super interesting character
who has become more and more prominent
over the last few years and that's Tony
Schwartz Tony Schwartz is the guy who
co-wrote or I guess I would say wrote
Donald Trump's book the art of the deal
and Tony Schwartz has become known over
the last several years as Donald Trump
ran for and became President of the
United States because Schwartz explained
what was going on behind the scenes when
he was writing the book for Donald Trump
he would explain that not only did
Donald Trump not write the book but that
Tony Schwartz would meet with him and
Trump couldn't even stay focused for
long enough to tell him a story that
then Tony Schwartz would sort of
synthesize and massage into being part
of that book Tony Schwartz also
mentioned not surprisingly the Donald
Trump has not read an entire book in his
adult life so that's Tony Schwartz now
we're hearing from Tim O'Brien Tim
O'Brien is a Trump biographer who wrote
a biography of Trump back in 2005 so
many years ago Tim O'Brien was
interviewed on MSNBC over the weekend
and said that the Trump presidential
campaign was likely a criminal
conspiracy that committed criminal acts
and my reaction was well yeah obviously
we didn't need Trump's biographer to
figure that out but he adds one other
interesting element which actually would
be newsworthy if it's true take a listen
to this what we've learned from this
raft of legal documents have landed in
our lap over the last couple weeks is
that there's a very real possibility
that the Trump campaign was a criminal
conspiracy from its beginnings and that
that that bled into the Trump transition
where various criminal acts might have
been committed and now you have the
Trump White House dealing with the
consequences of all of these so when you
have Rudy Giuliani as a sort of carnival
barker distracting people focusing only
on campaign finance issues focusing
inaccurately on campaign finance issues
it distracts from this larger
hallo of illegality that's hanging over
this entire Trump team so that's the
interesting new tidbit which is the idea
that this entire campaign was a criminal
conspiracy to begin with and the reason
that's important is that I've said
before I'm sort of more and more of the
mindset that Donald Trump on a whim
decided to run for president for
publicity didn't expect to win the idea
was if he can place a respectable second
or third in the Republican primary it'll
be really good for The Apprentice
reality show it'll be really good for
his real estate deals or whatever else
and that then the people that have had
Trump under their thumb for many years
started to realize hey hold on a second
if this guy can become president of the
United States we can get to him we can
use him we can manipulate him
so they started helping Trump and Trump
ended up winning and the criminality
sort of developed naturally if you can
use such a phrase what Tim O'Brien is
suggesting here is new in that he says
this was a criminal conspiracy from the
beginning which would be drastically
different in terms of its intent and if
this is true Pat the immediate question
becomes who put the criminal conspiracy
together because Trump's not smart
enough to quite frankly yeah I've gone
along with this idea that it was just to
promote the apprentice and then the
apprentice ultimately fired him after he
made his presidential announcement
speech and talked about how Mexico is
sending rapists and criminals so that
seemed to backfire not work out at the
very least I just wonder if they would
have been able to profit or get away
with crimes if he if he didn't become
president like if he had lost the
election would that still have been a
good bet for all those co-conspirators
to make was there another way for them
to profit off of this campaign well
you're talking about forces that are so
wealthy that it's just worth taking a
shot at I mean if it fails and Trump
doesn't become president you still have
Trump in your debt
which we know Trump has been for a long
time for many of the players that are
sort of manipulating him so I think it
was a it was a sort of gamble worth
making it was buying a lottery ticket
you might end up with nothing but if it
pays off that lottery ticket pays off
you know a million to one or whatever
analogy you want to use for it and in
terms of who my mastermind something
like that I don't know I mean you know
there's Roger stone in the sense that
Stone has been suggesting Trump run for
president for a really long time he's
connected he's competent but maybe not
supremely so then you've got Paul mana
for Paul mana for maybe has more
connections particularly in the parts of
the world that were interested in seeing
Trump become president of the United
States but mana fort was never really as
close to Trump as far as we can tell as
was Roger stone so was it stone and mana
Ford together with the help of others I
don't know the best possible outcome is
that whenever it's done whenever it's
over either because Trump's current term
ends prematurely after the first term
after the second term if Donald Trump is
reelected I don't know how long it's
going to be the best possible outcome is
that the Trump Fiasco destroys the
Republican Party for 10 to 15 years and
allows American politics to move where
the American people actually want on the
issues which is to the left to
sustainability towards science towards
an economy that works for everybody if
there is going to be any real upside to
this abortive attempt at a presidency it
would be the long-term damage to the
Republican Party the only counter to
that is Republicans seem to be
increasingly realizing that their party
is at risk and that's why they're
starting to say you know we won't
necessarily stick with this guy
indefinitely we'll see what happens